this time on life lengths sending our
reporters to travel around the world
doesn't exactly help the problem we're
talking about this week the problem of
climate change one of the biggest
challenges humanity faces gonna flies to
karabast
a group of islands which could soon
become a 21st century version of
Atlantis in the Arctic Circle David
learns why the whole Sami culture might
be on the line it's the people at the
margins of the earth who see climate
change happening for them it's no
abstract thing but a very concrete
threat right now use a hashtag to join
the conversation
this could be the first country to
disappear into the sea
welcome to cure Abbas the South Pacific
nation made up of 33 small islands
no one knows how long people can live
here if the global sea level continues
to rise so now lives on torella the main
at all she shows me that high tides and
storms are already wreaking havoc it
comes up to yeah yeah I like it's being
eroded mm-hmm and it's really fasting
and that's why we have we always afraid
or fear like having this high tides
they work to stop the rising water with
sand and cement that works quite well
as long as the weather stays calm though
it didn't earlier this year the first
thing came is the king tide and few
weeks ago later in the cyclone BAM we
don't have these experiences before but
nowadays we're starting to experience
this and risk and we see this with our
own eyes thinking that climate change
yeah is real is happening in air and
carapace the islands of Kiribati are so
small they don't even show up for many
world maps the highest point on South
Tarawa is just 10 feet above sea level
with flooding salty seawater flows into
the groundwater for washing the
contaminated water is still good but for
drinking the water can make people sick
many people drink it anyway because they
have no other choice
two months ago sand I helped to set up
rainwater tanks in West Village the
tanks will gradually be built everywhere
previously the children developed skin
rashes from the well water now they feel
better as long as it rains enough to
fill the tanks
I'm just so it's safe to drink
right mm-hmm
this one is much better
many people in Keira baths are poor and
unemployed climate change makes things
worse because so many residents are
dependent on locally grown fruit or
coconuts
breadfruit is a staple but the trees die
because there's too much salt in the
soil and water I think that's that's one
of that yeah the trees that died from
this sea water from the land and the
people in the seed like you know our
relationship is really that strong so we
take from this you know we our life
depend on this and death water so if
this destroyed
we cannot be destroyed as well the sea
is never more than a few steps or a jump
away of course the now loves the ocean
and yet at the same time it threatens
her future their agency in sea level is
quicker than before so imagine if it's
like every year I feel scared about this
just make the most of it enjoy myself
here without thinking of the bad things
in the future what
experts believe that by the year 2100
the sea level could rise by up to one or
even two meters such high water levels
wouldn't only threaten Keira bass the
major reason for the rise in water
levels is the sowing of ice caps and
glaciers as the planet warms gases like
carbon dioxide and methane form a layer
around the earth that's trapping the
heat in the atmosphere and turning the
planet into a greenhouse the burning of
fossil fuels like coal and oil
contribute massively to this greenhouse
effect the amount of greenhouse gases is
rising and so too is the earth's
temperature thing is we're all to blame
one major source of greenhouse gases is
transport even in Berlin where there's
not so much smog but plenty of smog
people taking public transport or riding
bikes like me basically everything we do
contributes to climate change that large
latte you pick up on the way to work 340
grams of greenhouse gases and that's
without the to-go cup even our research
for this show producing the electricity
for a 30 second web search results in
about a gram of greenhouse gases now
think about all the hours we spend
online
the average person here in Germany
produces about 25 kilos of co2 a day
that's 9 tonnes in a year just spend an
hour on your phone each day and in a
year you're producing over a ton of
greenhouse gases
here are the 10 countries that emit the
most carbon dioxide
one reason people aren't doing more
about climate changes that for most of
us it still seems kind of abstract but
the ways we're contributing to it
everyday are very concrete and my trip
to northern Scandinavia is about to
blast another 300 kilos of co2 into the
atmosphere
people here are already seeing the
effects of climate change it could even
mean the end of a culture large
Minghella is a member of the sami people
they've been living here in the arctic
climes of northern Scandinavia for
thousands of years in tune with the
seasons except now the seasons are all
out of whack
normally we would have snow by this time
it's a late winter this year and that's
something we've seen more of extreme
climates like the Arctic are
particularly vulnerable to climate
change and the fickle weather is a big
problem for these guys lars McKellen his
ancestors have been depending on
reindeer for food since before history
began now their way of life is under
threat we're here to help out large
Miguel's buddy Yann the reindeer are
still basically wild and they live out
in the wild but a few times a year the
herders chase them into Corral's to keep
track of them no one's here to look for
any reindeer that are his to take them
back to grazing lands closer to his home
don't worry
this parts almost over transporting the
reindeer means cutting off the male's
antlers so they don't fight in the
trailers actually reindeer aren't just
food for the Sami they're a central part
of the culture having reindeer around
when I grew up was a big part of giving
me a strong Sami upbringing and a strong
Sami identity is this maybe when you
feel the most Sami yeah you're really a
Sami you feel that you're really really
deep in the Sami culture when you're
when you're working with who in the
crowd a lot of key parts for even in
Sami culture comes and relies on
reindeer herding if you take people away
from reindeer herding they would lose a
important part of their culture
how do you know that it's yours every
ring their owner has its own brand okay
yeah it's like a little Halfmoon cut in
there yeah
and if you see a lot in the don't
downside uh-huh you can see the same
type okay little Halfmoon there and then
a triangle in here
most of the marks are by tradition going
by families that's like a DeMarcus
something very personal right yeah it's
kind of like a name
this last five seven years the snow that
has come it will melt and then it will
be water on the ground and then freeze
up again it's like that when they lay
their dicks down to this notes like you
can see the candy but they cannot get it
because it's I it's ice between the food
and him time to get some candy no ice in
the way for now by the way that thing
with the ice isn't new it's happened in
the past - but then it was a rare freak
occurrence
now extreme weather is the norm whoa
it's really soft
yeah this is what the Ranger eats lichen
it's a combination of algae and you like
it too don't you I'm sorry I've had
salads salads it don't taste this carrot
so this is what the reindeer dig sport
in the snow this is also coming at us
yeah we can taste really yeah they say
yeah it's like I don't want this to
become a popular dish though because we
need it for the Ranger probably has like
hair yeah with more and more ice in
winter the reindeer are losing huge
chunks of their grazing lands I mean if
they can't get to the lichens what's the
problem with just feeding them hey like
any other animal well the cost of this
well the thing with the Ranger is that
this is their natural food and feeding
them hay year-round is not normal for
them in reindeer in a Corral it's not
it's not made for that they make a
living for us in nature but to do that
they have to be able to get to this
stuff basically that's that's key for
their survival and you're gonna be a
reindeer herder yeah this kid
people here call themselves I care of us
they have lived in harmony with nature
for thousands of years the temperature
at night barely changes from the day so
most people sleep in traditional open
huts
then I studied abroad in Fiji a
three-hour flight away but she wanted to
come back to fight for the future of her
home
directly behind denies garden you can
see one of the biggest problems of Cara
bass there's trash on the beach as far
as the eye can see some was throwing
there by residents and some washed up it
looks and smells disgusting
most of this rubbish is not from the
environment
it's from the job or everything is from
the Western countries right water
clothes the plastic bags from heating
noodles from heating rice flour you know
hitting this process within foods that's
the beauty and that's so like it's very
sad because of climate change they are
limited on what they can grow themselves
so the I care of us have to import
evermore they haven't found the right
solutions for all the waste yet and
where are they supposed to put
everything the main island is densely
populated with around 50,000 residents
making up about half of the country's
total
many move here from other islands in
hope of finding jobs and education for
their children and those that find a job
often by a car
stuck in traffic world this is like
being in a big city not on a small I'm
small but complicated and they keep on
buying their car so do you think maybe
your people don't care enough about
climate change they don't care enough
because they they they don't know you
don't know what climate changes
just like in other parts of the world
importing Western lifestyle can make
everything worse
this bar also mixes Western and Pacific
cultures here a drink made from a plant
called kava is more popular than alcohol
and just as exhilarating
we're at the bar with Sinai's friends
many are activists who often talk about
climate change some of her friends are
members of KCC M which is the boyband of
the island
most of the people now they are kidding
afraid and they want to flee from the
country and I could see any good I feel
that it's gonna be alright
lost right this kind of chicken is this
couch you're singing dancing it must be
like the sami people are divided across
four countries Sweden Norway Russia and
Finland where we've come to a school
that trains reindeer herders well okay
yeah just barely alright
large McHale works for an organization
that fights for Sami rights he's
actually here chaperoning a group of
teenagers translating for them into
Swedish since they don't speak Sami
climate change isn't the only threat to
their culture the Sami language has been
lost in many places adapting to the
modern world also means the Sami have
given up their nomadic ways and that
industrial slaughter and butchering are
now part of the reindeer business but
industrial farming is out of the
question
yeah at least for now that's really what
will hurt me most to have to put the
reindeer into Corral's all the time
we want to have them out in the
in the woods and of course I mean that's
kind of an emotional part but that's
also economically it's really expensive
to have reindeer in Corral's and feeding
them every day for a full winter
peopleit reindeer need because it has
this game taste it's it has this you can
feel that they have been eating in it in
the nature
can I tell you a little secret time to
head back to Sweden no one's really sure
exactly how many Sami there are
estimates range from the tens of
thousands to the low hundred thousands
one thing that every indigenous people
has in in in its core is the closeness
to nature and the care for nature and
that's definitely true for the Sami we
can see some I mean changes results of
climate change in history here this
these lands have been better else then
you've got these birch trees and every
now and then we see dark pine trees they
are coming now slowly you know in a way
I feel kind of weird we're talking about
climate change and here we are driving a
minivan
well we couldn't ski these distances we
have to use machines we have to use
snowmobiles we have to use motorcycles
in reindeer herding nowadays the problem
is that we have developments industrial
developments we have roads we have
cities built in the middle of grazing
lands in Sweden always in Finland and
Russia so it's not that easy to do
reindeer herding as you did 100 years
ago because you have a lot of other
things in the way so that means that
even if you said climate change is a
threat to us in our way of life and to
reindeer herding you still have to drive
vehicles that potentially contribute to
climate change yeah that's well it's a
paradox in a way reindeer herding is one
of the few activities keeping Sami
identity intact if the reindeer starve
it'll be a huge blow to the Sami so what
does it mean if even large Miguel is
still driving cars basically like
everyone else
the Sami want a high quality of life
that also means enjoying products from
around the world we're back in Sweden
where every year the average person
drinks more than twelve hundred cups of
coffee importing the coffee pumps tonnes
of carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
large Miguel's friend Yanni is part of
the sami delegation going to the next
big climate conference she comes from a
long line of reindeer herders I was
brought up to always thinking that the
reindeer comes first
and the reindeer must must have a good
life and when the reindeer has a good
life we will have a good life but when
the land is changing our livelihoods
will be changing and from there our
language will be changing in our
traditional traditions we'll be changing
in our identities and that's us as
humans do you think there is reason to
hope of course there's always reasons to
hope otherwise I wouldn't be doing this
because I think that humanity has like
one we need to do something big hey
we've been to the moon then we can do it
not everyone here in karabast is
convinced their country can still be
saved the government even has a program
called migration with dignity part of
the program involves preparing young
people who lack the skills for the
global labor market and Kira basses
president spent more than six million
euros for a parcel of land in Fiji that
could house his people just in case it's
a lot of money for the tiny nation so
and buying this land in Fiji and
preparing migration with dignity yes you
call it and isn't that somehow admitting
defeat
no that's a leader there's my
responsibility to provide all the
options that I can't come up with some
people have criticized the fact that you
spent millions on that land in Fiji and
that it would have been better spent
here what would you say to them I simply
say they don't know what they're talking
about because they're talking from a
distance we need him to come here we are
spending millions just put in sea
defences to protect the road you can see
that there's millions of dollars already
and it won't protect the population in
the future so we're talking about a huge
amount of resources in order to deal
with this
we the countries affected no because we
are dealing with it we're not dealing
with it from a distance it's not an
epidemic it's not a theoretical exercise
it's a practical way of trying to
survive
look
millions flow to Kara bass in the form
of development aid from abroad largely
from the countries that cause climate
change soon I wants to do more to stop
climate change so she works with Climate
Action Network to educate others but
everyone here knows that things will
only really change if the big countries
emit radically less co2 at numerous
climate change conferences Polynesia a
loofa argued exactly for that what do
you expect from the climate conference
in Paris now I am NOT optimistic why not
because I couldn't see any any developed
country taking a a real big stand right
now you know on climate change to say a
yes we'll do this and I'm looking at
America you know the US and Europe
European countries if they take a spin
everyone will follow but they're not
taking a stand and why is that in my
opinion we are not ready to do it they
do not want to change your lifestyle
these big countries are all into oil you
know they're I think their hands are
tied and they wanna be tired they're not
prepared to leave it and move into
renewable energies then we move to
something else we're not prepared to do
that because once as as long as they
control the oil they can control maybe
the home world
Sweden is trying to do its part to stop
climate change actually the country is
looking to expand renewable energy the
Prime Minister even says he wants Sweden
to become the first country free of
fossil fuels pretty cool right well
large Miguel isn't so sure decades ago
Sami fishing waters and lands were
ruined by this hydroelectric dam if they
started as build a new dam I would be
standing on the fences and protesting
even if it could be part of the solution
to climate change yeah I think it would
be it would be better to build power
plants closer to the to the cities to
the industries instead of building it
here it's a it's an easy solution for
the people in the cities and to build
the power plants out of their view out
of their backyard and putting it on our
backyard instead temperatures in the
Arctic are rising two times faster than
in the rest of the world but Sami
activists are also worried about what
could happen when governments try to
tackle climate change
can I take one of your Sami knives yeah
take okay dick by now have helped
wrassle reindeer seem them butchered and
heard what they taste like
but this next part will definitely be
the hardest you could eat it just like
it is
but cream is cream is good wait so the
gem goes with the meat or with the
potato
well when you have a bite you'll have
some potato some meat and some Jack
alright ok it's the first time for you
eating meat like in 20 years or
something yeah let me think about this
it's been so I haven't eaten meat since
I was 5 I'm 29 so it's 24 years there we
go ok I guess we've we've been eating
reindeer meat forever I mean it was
hunted before it was being herded and
the people of a been eating game in this
region I guess since since the Ice Age
since the ice melted away
for a while L'Arche Miguel lived in
Norway been Russia he even thought about
moving to New York instead he came back
here because in the end what's more
important to him as keeping the Sami
culture alive I'm giving his kids as
strong Sami upbringing
if reindeer herding was suffering and
reindeer herding doesn't exist anymore
well that's not up to me
me personally I cannot affect that so
that's of course that would be hurtful
to see or to say to my future children
that I'm sorry you can't do this it's
not it's something that we did before
but it's not we don't have that anymore
and that would be a huge loss for for
for for them very good actually so to be
honest I don't know what the future has
in store for the Sami the reindeer will
survive this winter and the next winters
and I think large Miguel's kids will get
to work with them but I'm really not so
sure about his grandkids
the truth is it's kind of up to all of
us
we might be able to slow global warming
but experts are clear no matter what we
do from this point on a certain amount
of sea-level rise is already locked in
for our future deny knows this
nevertheless she's working to plant
mangrove trees that have the ability to
grow in very salty soil fully grown
these mangoes protect against coastal
erosion and storm tides God is giving us
this beautiful land so it's our
responsibility to look after it very
carefully even the coastal erosion is
happening climate change is happening
for real in carapace but still we we are
we're fighting right maybe it's a fight
that can no longer be won but it's
better to do something than just stand
idly by and watch
soon I will take it one step further and
attend the UN climate conference as a
youth ambassador where she will give a
talk about how cure Abbas is suffering
from climate change what's the
probability that these children will
grow old here on their Island this could
be the last generation of ikura bus here
or the first generation of climate
refugees I don't want to move no matter
what our biggest climate change is our
how scary it is to my life but I will
leave I won't live and you know because
I just
my country and I I'm so I always proud
of being me Cuba's and I don't like
living and moving away from here from
this place if they came here and if they
saw what it's like you think that would
change something yes I think it would
change everything what because you know
in their places they live what they want
and they do what they want but they
don't think about us because they
haven't been here yeah I mean they've
never seen and they've never heard about
here and they've never experienced such
a beautiful
tomorrow you don't have to go to Carabas
to know that our way of life harms the
planet today it's more important than
ever not just to know what to do but to
actually do it
one more time the Sun was amazing